Peggy's 16  well that could have gone better look  we've all lost dearly our people our  homes the light is getting snuffed out  soulless the last star and this motley  crew is all that is left to save it  we can in this yet we fight each other  over the scraps while the lesion of  cosmic horrors and a traitorous scum bag  consumed the universe got another  time to be the badasses we were born to  be live together or die alone ah yes car  hood  it's so cute how you think you can stop  sonus will you just called down the  thunder and dane we were born for this  I'm all ready to rock yeah little  something right here big guy huh so did  I get it yeah you're good okay  you